أريد أن أنتقل الآن إلى المحلل العسكري في سي إن،
اللفتنانت جنرال مارك هيرتلينج،
وهو القائد العام السابق
للجيش الأمريكي في أوروبا والجيش السابع، سيدي،
من الجيد أن تكون معنا، الولايات المتحدة ترسل
سفنًا حربية تابعة للبحرية والبنتاغون يعلن
دعم إسرائيل لإرسال جيش أمريكي
الأصول، ما هي أهمية هذه
المساعدة، والهدف، وما رأيك
في الطلب المحدد الذي
قدمته إسرائيل، ما الذي يمكنك قراءته في أن الأمر يتعلق
ببعض الأشياء، شكرًا لك ليلان أولاً وقبل كل شيء على
استضافتي، يتعلق الأمر بالمجموعة الضاربة لحاملة الطائرات
مجموعة حاملة الطائرات الفورد الضاربة هي قوة كبيرة
للردع أه في
المنطقة ليس فقط دعم إسرائيل
كحليف ولكن أيضا لمواجهة وردع
أي شخص آخر كما قال أورين في تقريره
أه أفعال الجهات الخبيثة لذلك لكن
هذا ليس الوحيد  الشيء الذي سيأتي هو أن
هناك أيضًا عددًا لا بأس به من الطائرات التي
ستتمركز في المنطقة، هذا
شيء عندما كنت قائدًا في
أوروبا، كنا ندعم في كثير من الأحيان حليفتنا
أوروبا، كانت تحت القيادة الأوروبية
في ذلك الوقت، وهي الآن تحت
القيادة المركزية للجنرال كيلا  من هو
قائد القيادة المركزية قد رأى أن هذه هي
أنواع الأشياء التي قد تكون مطلوبة في
المقام الأول للردع ولكن أيضًا أه في
احتمال أن يكون هناك بعض
الأمريكيين الذين تم أسرهم
وربما قتلوا وقد
يشاركون في أعمال للحصول عليها
يخرج هؤلاء الرهائن وينسقون مع
الإسرائيليين للقيام بذلك، لذا فإن هناك أغراضًا متعددة
لبعض هذه القوات التي تدخل
هناك الكثير من مخزون الذخيرة
داخل إسرائيل والتي يمكن أيضًا
إعادة إمدادها وهذا هو طلب
صواريخ أم إضافية للمساعدة في
أنظمة Iron Don هذا نظام
مشترك بين كل من الولايات المتحدة
وإسرائيل لذا هناك بعض المخزون إنه
من شركة تم إنشاؤها أه بين
إسرائيل والولايات المتحدة لذلك هناك
بالتأكيد أهمية كبيرة نظرًا
للكمية الهائلة من الصواريخ  الهجمات
التي تشنها حماس ضد
بعض الأهداف الرئيسية داخل إسرائيل